one of the most flattering things ever
to me was prob
ever because i have so much admiration
for you in my career
was you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk and i
continue playing around with an
interview format of just interesting
people
who are doing interesting things and
today one of my favorite entrepreneurs
and i'm excited to say that because i
have a very funny feeling
uh the millions of people over the next
five decades that listen to this or
watch this video
or listen to this podcast will will be
intrigued by
me stating my favor one of my favorite
entrepreneurs when i'm talking about
really one of the great music icons of
my generation one of the great
songwriters one of the great band
members one of the great music
personalities brian tedder is with me
today i think we'll talk about a bunch
of stuff
including our love affair with our great
friend eitan shukkerman
um but but more importantly uh i'm gonna
try some new things on this format i
decided because i love ryan's business
brain
and we're going to talk about some
current events and different things
and really just how humans work because
i think when you're a songwriter
uh at his scale just knowing what
humans will be touched by is a skill
it's i i feel like i have it in certain
ways i feel like others that i
observe have it and i think um ryan has
it
at the highest level so ryan welcome to
the show thanks for having me gary
how do you when people actually it's
funny that i said that when somebody
like literally
is on a plane uh here's a good one you
get on a plane
you know um and you're just flying and
somebody looks sitting next to you
just nice cordial combo you're about to
take off and she or he just says
hey so what do you do how do you answer
that
that's a really interesting question um
i do get asked that
on occasion and i'd say i typically say
i'm in a little bit it's a little bit of
that is my first answer
and because if if i get into what i do
specifically i kind of give them
phases to see am i going to engage this
conversation how far am i going to go
right when you say that when you say
that some people may just clam up and
pay
this guy's got two tattoos on his arms
maybe he's doing some shading or maybe
like
like you'll see how if they want to
double click into that correct
i see if they want to double click the
ad right so um i kind of i'm very nice
very cordial on airplanes um
and i've had some phenomenal
conversations but if they go further
than i say i'm in
uh i'm in music oh what do you do i'm a
songwriter i'm also a recording artist
um and i you know when you add the
record if you
if it's funny this is so interesting how
life works if you kind of have some work
to do or you're tired or not feeling
great or just don't want to engage
you may go all the way you may hold off
the recording artist part right because
if you just say songwriter
you can kind of wrap up and move on the
second photo recording artist like oh
who are you
yep correct 100 and a lot of times what
happens though on airplanes
um i'm not like that i'm at that kind of
comfortable level of notoriety or
celebrity where i get noticed like in la
or new york or wherever maybe once or
twice a day i get stopped
right um and they're usually very
respectful very cool
when i'm in an enclosed airplane for six
hours or whatever it is
that's i'm not trying to get stopped you
know what i mean
and this and the the flight attendants
very often know who i am and so that
will
kind of tee it off but more or less
you're right i try to see how far do you
want to go down this road i leave out
the recording artist i focus on
songwriting
and a lot of times i have great
conversations because people are
fascinated about songwriting they don't
understand it
so yeah it's i've had i've had that
conversation more times i can count
when did you consider when did you know
you wanted to be a songwriter and why
i knew i wanted to be a songwriter in
1994-95
when i found out that there was a guy
named babyface
writing all these boys to men records on
bended knee and like
into the road and then i discovered
diane warren
um and once i discovered that
how old how old were you i apologize how
old i was i was mid 90s i was 14.
and this was the first time you're like
wait there's humans that do that the
person that's singing it
isn't necessarily writing it oh that's
neat
that was the equivalent of being eight
and finding out santa claus wasn't real
because for most people they assume that
they're artists
and to some extent like bands very often
bands write their own material that's a
very like in
you know exclusive club but once i
discovered that a lot of my favorite
records
were written by three or four people um
it was like
oh my god that is the coolest job of all
time because
you get the access but you don't
necessarily have to be front-facing
um and so then i yeah i dove head-first
into songwriting but as i was doing that
i knew i wanted to be an artist i knew i
wanted to sing my own material
and so i was concurrently
developing my voice and playing guitar
piano drums bass i i was an only child
so i had nothing but time and weren't
either your parents musical
my dad was a gospel songwriter in the
70s
um all throughout this pretty much the
majority of the decade of the 70s he
toured he opened up for um you know
elvis back in the day he opened up not
him but like his group
he opened up for a lot of huge artists
in the um
in the 70s and he wrote quite a few
gospel records so yeah
he didn't pursue music but that he had
that window at time where he was about
to and then he didn't he didn't take the
jump at the end of the day
did he regret that yes
did that did that stick with you
did that become a really i love that you
know i talk so much about regret
and i think when people are fortunate
enough to have someone they have a good
relationship with and they love and
loves them
if they're able to take the best parts
of seeing someone they love have regret
it becomes an incredible
potion to patience correct correct
you're 100
right and i i knew that
he was less than thrilled with himself
for
he got offered a publishing deal
songwriter deal in la with a very famous
producer back in the 70s and he just
recently got married and long story
short
it was like that were you already on the
way or not yet
um i was not on the way i think i was
like
they were playing and they were thinking
they were thinking about entering your
parents you were in your parents minds
100 100 and my dad went to school
and was in a group with kathie lee
gifford and
she was this is wild this is why i'm not
going to make it good
and she ended up with a deal uh record
deal with cbs records and ended up i
mean she had stars in her eyes from day
one yes she did
and my dad and my dad wrote all of her
albums like like two albums in a row he
wrote all the material so he was kind of
on that bandwagon
headed west and it didn't go that way so
for me
because did he think it was the right
thing to do to not take high risk
was he a little fear like did he wha
what was his makeup did you extract that
of him was he
i would say i mean see yes so i'm
fear-based i'm from a
very religious upbringing christian oral
roberts like
i say to this day my parents and and and
uh lots of aunts and uncles are
very entrenched and so you understand
that paradigm
it is a fear-based decision make like
don't don't
you know you're you're getting married i
mean i'm not making that you're getting
they would say like an mrs degree like
get a misses degree like by spring
or else you know and so you've got
people getting married at 22
so they can have sex because they've
literally been virgins their whole life
there's a lot
right a lot of by the way by the way
that was very you know i
you know it's so funny i i was born in
communist russia where religion is
banned all of them
but everybody got married really young
for
the same reasons it was culturally in
the 70s more like the
u.s and the 20s in russia and so
you just didn't have sex out of wedlock
and when you're 18 19 and those
hormones are running it's like i was
literally born
nine months one day short of nine months
to the day of my parents wedding night
wow my parents got married on february
15th and i was born on november 14th
[Laughter]
that is wild i mean more or less that's
that's what i'm
that's what i came from i get it i get
it and uncle uh who are still
missionaries funny enough
they actually moved to communist russia
um
they lived there in the 80s before you
know uh that was the thing
yeah that was they they're they they
were followed by the kgb they were
handing out bibles and secret churches
um
so i'm i'm with you there and so that if
you understand that paradigm
that that kind of religious construct a
lot of your
decisions are informed by fear of
of correct godly retribution and god
will not approve of this god
told me to do this told me not to do
that and i'll tell you this much when
you're from oklahoma or arkansas like in
the south
um moving to l.a to pursue a dream or
new york
is you might as well go to mars it's
like mom i want to go to mars
and so for me your dad grew up in that
era and circumstances
yes where he was given ironically the
god-given talent
correct to do something yet the
framework of society and i talk a lot
about the internet
you and i are also very fortunate that
we're in the primes by
our careers with a scaled internet i
think i would be remarkable in any
generation
you know one of my favorite thing right
now is a bunch of fake entrepreneurs
running around
saying that they can't be as successful
because of biden
and i'm laughing like literally i'm like
i was successful during clinton i was
successful shows successful during obama
i was successful during trump i'll be
successful during biden
like real entrepreneurs win regardless
like you know but i also know that the
internet
really enables more scale yes um
and so i i just think about timing and
things that nature
so that was always in the backdrop for
you which probably
you you know could have worked either
way depending on your makeup and your
parenting
could have made you also scared or gave
you that
you had that spring in your step that's
what it gave me it gave me the spring
oh real quick i apologize you said that
baby face and all that hit your radar
yet your dad was doing it did you know
what your dad
was doing no so he was he was doing it
by the time that i was cognizant of what
my
my father was doing he was selling
like jewelry and well he was the guy
like if you're trying to get that hard
to get rolex or
was it was ryan was it as extreme as you
genuinely didn't know and then said to
your dad there's a guy babyface and he's
like i did this or you kind of knew in
the backdrop because it's your dad you
don't really put the two and two
together
i didn't connect it i i um i knew that
my dad
see my dad was in a group in the 70s so
i knew that he was writing
gospel but under the framework of his
own group they were called world action
singers
living sound they gospel blew up in the
70s
right and and um so my dad was doing
records with the like guys like leon
russell a lot of these la session
players and
but under the framework of his own band
so i still didn't connect that he was
writing for other people
and i thought that any time an artist
sang a song that they didn't write that
it was a cover song
that they were covering someone else's
previous hit like in the 70s when chris
christopherson would write something
covered so i didn't connect it and then
i ended up going to
i know i wanted to go into entertainment
i knew i wanted to create i knew 100
i had a i had a full scholarship for
acting which i didn't take
and i've been playing piano since i was
three started writing songs at 15
and all of a sudden around age 17
i had i wrote a couple songs that to my
ear
were as good as what was on the radio
and that's what i was aiming for
like i'm going to quietly workshop this
stuff until i'm good enough
to where the moment i step on stage
everyone's going to go where the hell
would that guy come from
so i won a record deal at 19 20 years
old on mtv
on trl and get this didn't tell my mom i
was going to new york didn't tell my
family i was going to new york none of
my college roommates
nobody knew that mtv was flying me to
new york
to play a song that i wrote by myself in
my dorm room
and all of a sudden my whole family
finds out that i can sing
write and perform all in the same day on
trl
and i won that [ __ ] out of here what
year was that
2000 2000 2000 2001.
so really in the like towards the like
tail end of the super hype of trl
correct it it was the peak of trl like
if i could
it was the peak of it because i was on
trl this is when carson was on there
or carson and diddy
correct it was the epicenter of culture
dude when i pulled up in times square
because a year before i went to new york
a year before almost to the day i went
to new york with a friend of mine
crashed to my uncle's church down in the
lower east side
went and hung out in times square i got
plucked out of the crowd to be on trl
they wanted me just like sitting in
front of the camera and to introduce the
number one video
and dave holmes or carson whoever it was
pulls me over to to drop a pin in when
this was he pulls me over
to um to like introduce number one and
he goes
because we got a brand new number one
this week from a brand new single and a
big debut for a new artist we think
she's gonna be huge ryan can you can you
intro it and i go well falling to number
two this week is the offspring
um which was uh you know i'm pretty
white guy
you know give it to me baby or whatever
that song was right and i go in the new
number one debut uh video for trl this
week
britney spears hit me baby one more time
that clip exists
that clip exists yeah
that was the year before and so then a
year later i end up on trl
and i in instinct was at its peak trl
was at its peak
and then um i win the record deal
timbaland is watching this show he
happens to watch this episode
my record deal doesn't really
matriculate into much of anything
over the course of next year i'm flown
to nashville l.a new york nashville
and timbaland calls me i moved moved to
uh new york upon graduation i'm living
in hoboken
and uh this group in atlantic records is
trying to sign me to be a part of the
group once i realized that this is not a
band it's a boy band i was like peace
i'm out
um timberlake actually was the one who
told me i've known justin since we were
both whatever 20 and he's like yeah
yo dude you don't want to do that man
boy bands are going out bro you want to
get out
so doubt
is much stronger that was really well
done dude it's not bad bro it's not bad
um when i go to nashville
one day i get a phone call from a from a
virginia beach number 757
i still remember the number and it's
timberland who at the time at the time
biggest producer alive by a landslide
you're right
this is just like how i love life yeah
look at this look at my latest
is that all time that's incredible there
it is life how funny life is keep going
it is small full circle right so so yeah
so he
he ends up he ends up calling me so he's
a yo dude i saw i saw that show on trl
man he's like man you tight you
tight bro you tight you know so he flies
me to new york
manhattan center studios and he's
working at the time with like debate
like uh who birdman and whoever else
and i signed with timbaland for two
years i followed timbaland around
the america i moved to miami i'm with
timberland living in his apartment in
aventura
um crashing on his bus i'm with scott
storch he is i was with him the day he
wrote crimea river the demo i mean he
came in the bus he said right get in my
bus and like he comes in and plays me
the demo
and i was like that's a yo what like i
couldn't even understand it
i was there for the you know future set
love sounds that whole album sexy back
nelly furtado missy elliott the first
session i have with him in dallas i
remember
missy elliott was there usher was there
jt was there and they did
um if they're on up a tip down yeah
like is it worth it let me work it put
your thing down flip it and reverse it
and so
i watched him at his creative genius
apex changing culture and i took that
in about a year and a half later i got
my first cup of bubba sparks and about a
year and a half into working with tim
i was in colorado for christmas whatever
hanging out
pulled up my mpc sat down i was like
well i got to write my own stuff and
like pretty much the first thing i wrote
was apologize and i had tim's drums
because i had a bunch of timberland
sounds and i just made up
like threw the piano down and then you
go oh
that sounds like a band i think i'll
call it republic and then it became one
republic and
that's kind of the the five minute
synopsis on that whole
journey from trl to one republican we
were the last band
along with paramore to play trl before
they turn the lights off
which i thought was really kind of
simple yeah
yeah when i introduced
intro to you just now and said
entrepreneur how did that land in your
own mind you're like oh gary's being
nice oh he's right or it's cool that
gary sees me that way or
it's it's neat that he sees that or yes
i am or i can't wait to do more like
how did that land probably a little bit
of all the above
um i'm so used to being introduced a
songwriter but ultimately
or an artist but that is an entrepreneur
you're you're manufacturing something
out of nothing
figuring out where culture sits with
what you're creating
finding that true market fit of your
record and the reason i got into
entrepreneurial funny enough that the
the degree that i was pursuing initially
in college was a
entrepreneurial ship degree um and
i just like creating things man and and
you said something really interesting
thing a minute ago you said
you know the connection between writing
a hit record or a hit tv show or
whatever
and the parallels between investing in
something or creating something creating
a brand or a company
that also resonates with the world
they're so similar
bro i'm blown away i mean we've talked
about this off screen
like one of the most flattering things
ever to me was pro
ever because i have so much admiration
for you in my career
was maybe 18 months ago when we started
talking more often and you're hitting me
up of like hey gary your
music understand like you know these
people like yeah
it's like about you know i've always
yeah just
it to me the baby and
tick-tock and supreme
or kif or or or
bushwick or dumbo real estate it's all i
just play one game
of i'd see something before somebody
else sees it because i understand human
beings
dude that is my whole game right now i
i started investing um years ago
uh in you know alongside guyosiri and
ashton initially
abe burns who ran that investments
became my homie
then paul walked her got connected with
a lot of the different kind of like
forecasting minds in los angeles and
and obviously not you know goes without
saying you in new york
and picking things investing in things
that to me i use myself as a litmus test
as a barometer if i like something i see
so much [ __ ] around the world traveling
around the world 300 000 miles a year
i see stuff popping off in madrid new
zealand sydney hong kong
and when you are constantly injecting
yourself
into global culture listening listening
tapping in and paying attention
inevitably 20
of the comments on this youtube video
are gonna be like gary stop being a dick
ryan has so much good to say stop
interrupting him
and and i always think about him like my
god i'm so hyper listening
so intuitive i know what the person's
gonna say i know that this is over in 22
minutes i want to get to so much [ __ ]
i knew what he was going to say but i'm
a i'm not the greatest
interviewer because i need to mature
in my life in making sure the full
audience like
i don't know what you're going to say
something cool boom quit you know the
way we would eat dinner
but meanwhile there's other people
listening like no no i wanted ryan to
finish i thought i'm like
what you didn't understand what the
thought was it was it you know like and
so
yes it's lit it's listening dude it's
listening and then what happens is
you for anybody watching it starting a
company wanting to invest in startups
seed funding whatever you're doing
it's listening paying attention um you
know my dad would always say the 11th
commandment
in in the bible is thou shalt not
[ __ ] thyself
that's the 11th commandment don't
[ __ ] yourself don't just because
your mom likes
awareness your mom likes it your
girlfriend likes it cool we're talking
about
the world liking it and i think being
real and honest being your own worst
critics you're not being
judged in the court of public opinion
but you're really critically thinking
when you put something together
and i think like you said gary it's it's
listening
and finding that thing here's one clue
for me
if i keep complaining about something
and i'm not a big complainer i don't
like complainers i don't like
people who complain and then don't
provide a solution don't
my whole team that works with me knows
don't come at me with a problem if you
don't have
you know and i want you to have a lisa
hypothesis
a hypothesis don't just go boom and then
walk out of the room
um so for me it's like if i find myself
being irritated
about the lack of this or i mean i wish
this existed i wish this thing whatever
once i do that enough that's that's why
i'm fine i go
wait a minute is that why you're
creating more products these days i know
that like it feel like
i feel like every 100 days i get a text
from me like dude i need to talk to you
in a week i got
and that fires me up yeah i'll give you
i mean you already know about i've been
in
you know the cbd water thing i found cbd
as
an as a much needed panacea for stress
i'd gone through a really bad patch in
2017 16. i've just
i've worked it too hard i found the wall
i hid it burned it both
pick your analogy burnt it at both ends
didn't like uh
xanax didn't like wanting to be on drugs
at all um discovered cbd my
my high school guys that i graduated
high school with started charlotte's web
which is the largest knee companies in
the world they they gave me the medical
shake down on it i fell in love i'm a
true believer so i got into the space
you know um and i didn't like how it
tasted i didn't i mean
i'll give you just two quick i didn't
like how cbd tasted i didn't like the
the medicinal plant flavor and then i
also at the same time
crush a lot of coffee don't drink enough
water and i thought
what if you took cbd everybody's on
functional beverages made it taste good
add it with water did the whole tom
shoes give back
you know one for one like have a social
imperative buying your company that's
another thing
don't just be a profit monster have a
social imperative um
right can i ask you something about that
i apologize yeah how do you think about
that because i
i think that there's two ways to do that
right like like
i when empathy came out correct right so
many people
in my inner circle debated like [ __ ] the
name let's do the tom shoes let's do the
give back
and i'm like look i give back all the
time we're gonna give back
i don't think you know sometimes if it's
not fully authentic to your
yeah if you're gonna do it yeah there's
a caveat to that
if you're going to do it there are
certain brands like
i mean to be quite honest gary with
empathy i don't know what i would do as
a
that's not that's a weird one you know
the cool thing is with that one with
such a broad name you could have picked
anything because
being empathetic to any group of people
would have allowed the permission
yeah yeah i mean were you to start the
brand right now i have a feeling you'd
probably find an affiliation
you know what's funny though i wouldn't
because i feel like right now and my
my mind changes all the time right now i
feel like those are
forced yep and like i'm very happy
about my give back initiatives i also am
pretty private
about my you know much like i'm with my
personal life i'm very private with my
give back
i've gone a little louder with like you
know pencils of promise and
chapter water things i'm on the boards
of but um
so and you made it i think i think it's
give a quick plug because i cut it off
because i was curious i wanted people
i was i've we have so many young people
listening who are
putting businesses together and i want
to make sure that they felt that they
didn't
have to do the give one back when you
know you don't have to it has to be
authentic to you
for me adele's husband simon konecki
ex-husband was a friend of mine
he ran a non-profit called drop for drop
which is function
tom schuster blake mykoski is advisor
blake is joining the board of matt tasty
walter rob a whole food ceo joining the
board
how long how long have you been through
i've been talking a lot about mad tasty
over the last three months
um we've been around for about a year
there it is there's the unicorn tears
that's one of the flavors i'm actually
cut and then i'm actually drinking this
one right now
watermelon kiwi so 20 milligrams cbd all
natural
um five calories and we we we are
building our seventh well
right now in india and we're building
another one of malawi and so what we do
is every you know
we we donate 12 ounces of drinking water
so we you if you buy a can we donate 12
ounces what
the equivalent is we build clean water
wells because that is a huge epidemic
i think i mean charity water has been
literally the most
i mean it's unbelievable when you get
educated on how many people around the
world don't have fresh water
it's crazy people are dying from
diarrhea kids like thousands millions
like it's insane
so so that this is taking off we're up
you know give you hard numbers we're up
70
this quarter from last quarter and 100
from the quarter before it's taking off
uh the fda regulation with cbd's tricky
let me
let me let me ask you a quick question
that while you were talking i was trying
to let you talk so i didn't interrupt
but i felt it i i
took everything i had to not
i have a question i'm dying to know and
i'm sure will be a fun story
yeah so you and i are fortunate we have
this intuition of the
consumer yeah from a music standpoint
where have you been crazy off what
record did you hear
mm-hmm and you're like this yeah i don't
think it happened
not gonna happen and then went and
slayed america
or artist where you're like not on not
on some like guessing [ __ ] on like
you sat you looked because we've all
been there right we've passed on airbnb
i passed
like where did you where did you where
did you uh
really miss it um i really miss so every
year
there's one or two records that i'm
completely off on like every year
and songwriters have this conversation
all the time like we pride ourselves in
guessing oh that's a hit that's not a
hit that's
of course of course um i was wildly off
on and it's the biggest record of this
past year by a
landslide i was wildly off on blinding
lights the weekend
um interesting by the way everybody was
like
and you never made me wrong i love the
song not not throwing shade at the
weekend i love abel you didn't
you didn't think you didn't think the
audience was going to get it nobody did
nobody i mean it why was it brought up
and it was written by a couple of my
friends like
one of the best pop summers of all time
max martin um
and abel because when it came the first
single they dropped
didn't connect it was the fastest fall
in the hot 100 history
and yeah that's true and
uh no no there was a record i don't even
remember the name of it but they dropped
it
and i think it was in a car no then they
got lining lights anyway so
this is back at the beginning pandemic
now they dropped it right before the
pandemic so there's only about two or
three
artists that have momentum going into
the pandemic those two or three artists
maintained and kept that momentum for
the last nine months do aleppo
there was a weird chart freezing
situation that happened there was three
or four months where i swear to god the
top ten in spotify
didn't move by more than two songs
because they just they just froze
right all the uber drivers went home
people weren't going through their
playlists
it just everyone's watching the news
they weren't there wasn't that much
you know chart movement the weeknd got
the benefit of that a handful of records
do alipa got the benefit of that
but the week in blinding lights i think
if you asked abel himself did you think
it was
as big as it is he would start laughing
i know i know fact the label didn't
think that
nobody when you're in songwriting
sessions that song gets brought up a lot
lately because everyone has the same
response they go
did you see that coming nobody saw that
coming and it is the single
biggest streaming hit it will go down
it'll break every single record
within the next 90 days streaming
records it's gonna pass ed sheeran
what do you think what do you think
about tick-tock's impact
on the top tick-tock so um i'm you know
friends with a lot of people who are
having some some massive success in
tick-tock right now my friend
jay cash i spoke with yesterday wrote
savage love for derulo derulo
i'm very tight with i just did a record
with him a week ago we're
having conversations he um
his career his career has been
completely rekindled by that plan
embodied
tick tock you caught you saw tick tock
come in i mean i believe
from day one i knew that this was going
to be a huge mover um
from a from a mainstream he
is the khalid was snap yep yep
yep ashton ashton was twitter
mood 24 karat golden right with that
dude in ian dior
that is a that record was written with
tick tock in mind
right this is the weirdest weirdest day
this interview is all time hold on
i just gotta show you this synchronicity
synchronicity when i tell you
like you know what's good gary's 24k
gold in here and i got a question for
you today right
yep is that just so crazy you and i are
very much on the same wavelength rise
dude we're on the same wave i'm going in
with with
uh blake slack that the whole crew
that's that's part of the ian new york
golden crew um been working with kid
laroy a bunch
um look the tick tock thing in the last
so i did an analysis
about six months ago five months ago um
in the top
20 16 of the top 20 songs had gone off
on tick tock
yeah so here's the upside i'm gonna talk
a tick tock for 30 seconds and i'll get
off
the upside the downside and where i
where i personally think might happen
with tick tock
number one the upside is um it's removed
barrier to entry it's
it's gate crashed the the festival that
is streaming and radio and spotify
um and so artists at this point who
might not have had a shot like josh 685
from new zealand he's a 17 year old high
school kid in new zealand and he's gonna
make probably five million bucks off
savage love that's the truth probably
more
um and so everyone's like oh i gotta
write songs
you can't game tick tock you can pay the
top 10 or 20 people to dance your record
but ultimately they have created it in
such a way that they actually
if they think a record label is gaming
it they'll kill it they'll kill that
virality so
it truly is a direct reflection of
culture
now here's that's the that's the
positive thing about tick tock here's
the negative thing
the best song doesn't win right
historically my whole career
and i'm quoting two record label
executives right now that
i've heard in the last month say the
same thing historically
you could always say no matter what
happens or what weird fat is going on
guys the best song still wins
with tick-tock that's not the case you
have it it
isn't so much to do with the record
itself it reminds me of the ringtone
moment moment in the early 2000s when
you had happy frog and these different
songs popping off
it's not about the best song it is about
the dance the virality the culture
attached to it
one one could argue i mean not only
could one argue
i can't believe what just happened i
literally had i've literally heard what
you just said before in my life
when the original manager of the styx
was talking to me about mtv yep
he said what mtb did was ruined it
because the best
records didn't win anymore yeah i don't
think tic tocs ruined it
stick with me here because this is a
super interesting moment one could argue
what tick-tock is right now is what mtv
was in the mid-80s that through the
entire thing for a loop
which is when you added the visual
element and you added the fact that
every teenager was in one place
the best song got redefined because
ultimately the only person not you not
me not the executives
not not the academies the consumer wins
and if the consumer's attention is a
certain place and there are added
variables
of the full-pledged artistry whether
that's charlie demilio
24 gold whatever it is it is that market
is always right
yep if you could change the change that
change the um
definition right what i would say to
that is
um the most consumed song wins the most
the most engaging song based on visual
and or song and or artist
wins um the kind of the the analogy that
someone's saying is
do you think adele rolling in the deep
right one of one of the biggest most
iconic records of the last
decade or longer would rolling in the
deep go off in the age of tick tock in
2020
but one could argue that the greatest
songs that we all know
in the 50s and 60s if they didn't pay
the the radio disc jockeys i would argue
that this game has always been the case
and that the relationship of
distribution
and who does or doesn't control it at
that moment
or how controlled or uncontrolled is it
is a huge variable you being an
entrepreneur for example you dropped it
very lightly already in here
we've never really talked about this but
i've this is why i've always
desperately admired you from afar and
again i mentioned it earlier eitan
sugarman a great friend of both of ours
a great great friend
um you know really was like
the person i most you know i knew of you
but like just to talk about the quality
of who you were so like you know to me
it's like someone's a nice person and
hardworking
like i'm already on third and a half
base
but like you talked about earlier about
the song in a commercial
yeah you know your ability to be an
entrepreneur in my opinion
from afar and think about things like a
commercial
yeah which is hugely financially
valuable and distribution for awareness
yep i always talk about it i call it the
good charlotte rule good charlotte on
madden
on repeat when people were doing
franchise mode in those early days
really mattered i think about
distribution all the time
i would argue that adele's song is
remarkable
remarkable and was in the right place at
the right time for distribution
and that had it been 20 years earlier
i have a funny feeling adele song would
not win in 1999 trl land
because she didn't look the part to a
lot of people yep you're correct timing
timing is every timing is everything so
here we go right then sync was how big
nsync was
if you brought out five dudes right now
that are american five white dudes
not gonna have to amer to america five
white guys to america right now
probably not going to be the moment
about the least wavy thing you could do
right now is put a five piece white
group together
or maybe the counter move is the other
way and maybe it does
this is what i love about the market
yeah the market
being the judgment i think all that tick
tock is doing is getting the same
points of view from the establishment
that
has always happened always whether it
was
soul train and dick clark and and casey
cason
whether it was mtv whether then it was
youtube and
whether it was spotify whether it's like
there will always be a new variable that
comes and is more consumer-centric
yes and then whoever is adaptive to that
consumer centricality is going to win
and then whoever's not
is going to say this isn't real music
it's this rap is not real
this well duran duran sucks that's not
could you i mean this is your world yeah
i couldn't even imagine what the
real bands of the late 70s and early 80s
i mean that's why i brought up the stick
story because when i found this
gentleman in a different meeting
i grilled him for an hour and a half
because my
thought of what the clash would [ __ ]
you know led
zeppelin and like like like ac dc
thought when duran duran and twisted
sister and rat took over because they
were
mtv centric yep yep you're 100 right i
mean look i've produced
the last two u2 albums i've produced the
killers i work with a lot of bands i'm
working with bastille right now
it's a weird time in general for bands
it's a weird time for bands it's a weird
time for bands you know coldplay biggest
band in the world dropped a double
album earlier this year and a lot of
people don't even know what happened and
they're
one of the biggest bands in the world i
didn't i didn't and i'm a
and i'm an enormous fan of their sound
there you go i pay attention like a
[ __ ]
no no clue i just told you now you're
going to go online you go holy [ __ ]
there's there's two albums here you know
what's so funny about zigzagging
it makes me want to start a band yeah
like to me right now the opportunity to
build like the monster
band feels real sonically that's where
it's headed
so i i can't what does that mean the
demos so
things happen musically right right the
musical trends
come out before the you know the beauty
of what i
do or one of the things things the
reasons i consider myself lucky is i get
to hear
where the world's going to be at nine
months from now
and it comes it starts with the song in
the studio that's
that's capturing current culture but
talking about other stuff
and you get to hear those records like
six to nine months before they come out
so like
you can kind of it's it's a bit of a
nostradamus lens
and you're saying if you listen it's
kind of like how i felt about tech or
what i do with influencers you're saying
so i'm yelling a lot about men's makeup
yep like i've said for about 18 months
now if i was to start a company
from scratch right now and i had to do
it i couldn't do vayner anymore
and my model i would start a men's
makeup brand and it's coming because i
already
see it because i see it broad enough
back to new zealand e-boys
you're saying because you listen to so
many things that are coming you're like
wait a minute
the and then if you're good at this game
oh look what's happening
from this hip-hop artist to this band to
this pop girl they're all
there's something's happening here and
it's this thing so to that point
i've heard some demos from some people
we've already mentioned on this
on this interview and from some other
huge artists that are in that space
and everything is leaning banned
it is going this sonically i heard a
record last week from a guy that um
just just now popping off in l.a like
under like way off
radar but i think very prominent and it
was
basically it was it was literally
blink 182. i mean it was a it was like
it was somewhere between blink 182 and
good charlotte and like
throwing it's so obvious that that can
happen right now
listen to the instrumentation listen to
circles post malone there's a there's a
forecast
hundred percent at the wave right that's
a way that's not just a one-off song
you're gonna have whole bands and
artists
that started because of one song little
rapid-fired underrated who's the most
underrated artist in your subjective
opinion right now or
if you know it's a tough question like
one or two just
who's right now in your opinion fairly
new just
underrated right now fairly new
underrated artists yeah
wow that's a great question or they
don't even have to be fairly new maybe
they're actually very big
and you're actually like man people
think this person made it
wait till they see the next decade of
her or his or their
potential um i mean that is such a good
question i think that i think that uh
i mean post is already so big i mean a
lot of the artists that i work with are
let's talk about that like post actually
it's funny i think i asked ask the
question because you said post i
actually think post has the potential
to be underrated because i i actually
believe that
yeah i agree i so i would in anybody
that works with him would tell you the
same thing
i think post is underrated you know why
he's so big he's so big
yeah he he is truly though beyonce and
drake were so big
and were underrated and went on to
become bigger yep yep absolutely
sway lee uh look sway lee
is one of the most freak of nature
talents
melody contrivers in the world a guy can
the guy will come up with melodies and
phrases
that reminds me of when tricky in the
dream
created rihanna umbrella and the first
time anyone heard that
like that was that started a whole wave
right and
he sway lee has that ability he has that
talent sway lee if he connects the dots
could be one of the absolute biggest pop
artists that that are around
rightly you feel has the ingredients he
just has to cook it
correct he has to cook it um by the way
everybody's listening right now
when i talk about this in sports in
entrepreneurship in music and acting in
in being a cfo of a company
i have watched in my young i turned 45
this saturday
in my young 45 years i've seen so many
people that had every ingredient
but couldn't get out of their ways of
insecurity ego
uh lack of work ethic uh like uh
serendipity a tragic
end in their family didn't let them get
there in sports you see people get hurt
there's there's different things and you
know team so
who your team is it is such a limited
group of people that can
that can absolutely displace you or
influence you positively
in in your career and if you have if
someone in your team
isn't firing on all cylinders they can
whether knowingly or unknowingly
completely sabotage
your future with whatever that is like
company yeah like a band dude you got a
ban you got a bad manager
i went through a handful of managers
before we landed with the one that i
have now i have the same manager of
pharrell and um usher and a handful of
others he's brilliant one of the best in
the business we're on the feet it took
me
three or four chapters of managers and
getting dropped by columbia records i've
been dropped twice
you know like it took all that to for me
to land the right manager and i learned
the lesson of who your team is
is everything it's absolutely everything
it's critical so yeah i think i think
swaley's underrated
taylor swift as big as she is nobody's
been in the studio with her like they
haven't
seen what like i've seen her her her
actual innate ability
um exceeds just about any human being
that i've ever
ever seen she's she is the best
like solo writer that's that's recording
music right now she can sit down do a
whole thing by herself it's phenomenal
um the single greatest musician in the
world now i don't know if
you consider this person underrated or
overrated i just don't think he's talked
about enough i think he's
admired but the single most impressed
i've ever been
musically um by anyone is stevie wonder
he is there's no one alive no one alive
that is he is the physical embodiment of
music
i would i would argue that he's he's
uncomfortably underrated
uncomfortably there you go i'll tell you
why i
you know maybe the reason i just asked
you this to wrap up because i gotta run
i'm sure you do as well
i uh i did this little you know
instagram tick tock show called
overrated underrated
and i don't know the questions and my
team just blurts out stuff and it's yeah
i thought i thought that was what we
were doing
yeah you know it's funny like and anyway
i said the beatles were underrated and
the comments exploded they're like how
is that
your herbs are right i think they are i
don't think i think i think most people
under 35
struggle to understand it in context as
they should because i understand who's
going to do the homework
i think stevie wonder stevie wonder was
winning at
10 yeah winning at 10. at 10. i just
can't
think of that i just real quick i
apologize 10.
most of you have a 10 year old in your
life yours
your brother your sister 10 10
one of the biggest stars in the world at
10.
yep and the only artist to win
back-to-back uh best album grammys
within two within a year of each other
he did two albums in a row one
grand you know album of the year two
years in a row the man
is the single most talented musician
alive i put my name on it
paul mccartney i produced his last album
we had we had the first number one paul
mccartney album in 35 years
and i watched mccartney jump around his
studio in england
playing every instrument which by the
way they were the instruments
from sergeant pepper you have all of
them still there that's what he uses
and i walked him i watched him bounce i
go paul get on the drums and i hit
record and then he'd do the drum solo
paul get on piano
get on the harpsichord [ __ ] amazing
the man is 74 and he bounced around for
five days playing everything it was it
was like
i mean that's the you know you know what
right i'm gonna end with that how old
are you
uh i'm 41. great ryan's 41 i turn 45
like i said on november 14th depending
on when you're listening to this
paul mccartney 74 still doing it when
you find what you do
what you love when you're at it for all
you 20 [ __ ] year olds that listen to
this [ __ ]
and get mad at me when i talk about
patience it's early
oh my god what were you what were you
doing when you were 22 years old when i
was 22 years old
i was living in nashville
writing songs signed to timberland
trying
uh absolutely broke i was broke until i
was 20
26 absolutely flat broke by the way for
everybody
to understand this one of the like one
of the great talents that of course
there's going to be people in their 20s
like ryan that get there
i'll use myself at 26 i didn't have fun
anything about anything about anything
other than
i was building a liquor store for my
dad's business like i was building a
business for him
so i think that patience matters and
when i hear the 74 year old story of
mccartney like that [ __ ] fires me up
this was a lot of fun ryan i love you i
wish you man thank you gary
thank you seth for producing we'll talk
soon bye everyone leave some comments
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon